Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast and, Huh?
Just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
Duda Duda Hey, guess what? What?
I uh, I am fucking on it this
year when it comes to Christmas.
Hey, Christmas. Go Fuck
Yourself. That's what I'm saying.
I'm talking all kinds of shit.
I'm backing up.
I'm wagging my fucking
head at your Christmas.
I'm sorry. I'm just excited. I got all my
shit wrapped and I shipped it out that,
hey,
fuck you over.
Over.
That's it. All you need to do
is get a pair of Jordans, right?
Whatever the fuck verse he says
in it and that's it. It's over.
The greatest fucking feeling ever
this holiday is like, you know,
when you become an adult, it's dreadful.
It's like, Oh fuck man, I gotta you know,
I got to bring the kid over here.
I gotta fucking get this person something.
Oh Jesus, what do I gotta get this guy
a calendar or something. I got a show.
I got to show him how much I care about
is stories that have no fucking point.
You know,
God at least get him a stocking stuffer
for how many minutes of my life did he
wastes this year. Just the, the, the, the,
the fucking stress of that.
Um, I gotta tell you something,
buying the things and wrapping him,
slapping a name on them and then
once you mail that fucking thing,
it's like a high, heavy, like runners
talk about like runner's high,
you know,
which is hilarious because if you look
at the look on their face when they're
running, it does not look like
they're enjoying themselves.
Every person I've ever seen jogging
down the street, like not everyone,
but most of them,
they look like they should acquit.
Like two miles ago they'll
lean into one side.
They kind of got that fucking stroke mouth
going. You're not, they'll fucking one.
It's like to have just enough already
enough. We get it. We get it. We get it.
You're a, you're, you're, you're a
fitness fucking group guru. Slowdown.
Walk Goldman at a Taco stand. All right.
Get yourself a fucking Taco or something.
All right. Just relax. Um,
who do you hate more joggers
of bike riders? Yeah.
Who Do you hate more joggers
of bike riders? Neither.
I like everybody on the poverty of
force that balances out your life.
Get the hell out of my office.
And you crushed on the podcast.
Let's see if you've got another one in.
You don't hit me. I gotta go. I gotta go
to the gym by you're going to the gym.
What for all Hollywood? You're trying
to get you abs going for 2018 yeah,
a beefcake.
Alright,
bye. Um, oh wait.
Oh Jesus. The anticlimactic. Then
you've got to come back. Come on.
Give me a kiss goodbye. Let me kiss
goodbye now. Actually, you know what?
Give it to me when a gum, when you
come home. All right, I'll see.
[inaudible] gross. Oh, I got all the tags.
Knee up for the gifts and stuff.
Sarah's. Yup. And I try to make your Nia,
when I said from uncle bill and Antione,
I try to make it look like
your handwriting, but it
clearly looks like mine.
It doesn't need to be.
Plus I'm left handed so it's smudge to
cross and I forgot to sign your name to
the card. The one that said
how much we care about them.
It's the second time I've done that.
You are the worse.
There's going to be a lot
of Hosta. I didn't do that
to you. You No, I'm kidding.
Come back please.
Um,
the fucking shit that women are into.
It was just, you know, she got a car.
Did sign my name to, what
about you? All right.
How could you do that?
Everybody's getting sick care.
No, they're not. They
have lives. Um, anyways,
I got the shit fucking rap.
I got,
I got like one more thing to get my laugh
and have all of that fucking wrapped.
All right. And I just see, hey, you go,
alright, here you go. Leave me alone.
And then I'm gonna I got,
I'm like eloquently come off the wagon.
I'm still on the wagon. I
got 15 weeks in. All right.
I'm already a third of the year
in 26 weeks is half a year,
but that takes me into February and
I'm going to the rose bowl so that,
that's the next tough one.
That's the next hurdle I have to get
past is if I could somehow go to the rose
bowl and not get all fucked up,
which I've done before. I've done it.
I don't think I've done a couple of
times. I've done the Rosebowl sober. Um,
I don't know what, but, uh, I'm
actually, I was thinking the other night,
like when I come back to drinking,
all right,
when we rekindle our relationship,
you know, like you have a c,
there was a particular person out here in
Hollywood, had an abusive relationship.
Skye was beating the shit out of her and
stuff, and then she went back to him,
you know, being like, no,
we fixed it this time.
And I remember the talk show
hosts were like going like,
are you sure you know what you're doing?
This is me going back to boots. Um,
with my little barbed wire tattoo.
Um,
I think I'm just going
to go straight to heroin.
Like I for some reason feel
like I can handle it at my age,
you know,
cause I know how stupid it is to do.
I would just do it like one time and
just be sitting there like right in the
living room to just don't, don't have
the shame that most junkies have.
You just sit down with your
family and just say, listen,
this is something that I want to try.
I'm just going to do it once and I would
appreciate it if you guys would hang
out during my entire high and make sure
that I don't tip over and bust my head
open on the coffee table with ava.
We have the kid proof things around it.
It'd be actually a lot of that kid proof
shit becomes junky proof after a while.
You know, I'm, I'm kidding. And
I'm not making light of the, uh,
nationwide heroin epidemic,
but we all know that the nationwide heroin
epidemic is not the biggest story in
the country right now.
That's not the biggest story.
It's not that they've poisoned our food
supply fellow Americans. It's not that.
It's not that after all the protests is
still going to put that fucking pipeline
and it's not that. What
is the biggest story? Huh?
Matt Lauer buying a fucking Dildo
for the stand in weather person.
It's not that
having a president who's out of his fuck.
Nate's not debt.
The biggest story in the United States
of America right now is Eli Manning is
being sat on Sunday and it's 210 game
streak is coming to a close and all of New
York shut down.
They couldn't believe that Alicia Manning,
I didn't know his name was Alicia.
I have never seen such a
fucking ridiculous reaction
while ignoring real fucking
problems.
There's like 30,000 fucking tornadoes or
whatever the fuck we had. Hurricanes, Eh,
have fuck all that Miami is.
Give me on the water,
like delay the fucking texts that
I got from New York sports fans,
my friends, like the level that they
were having a fucking meltdown, you know,
fuck the roper dope that's going on in
the Middle East right now where you got
to fucking band a fucking 3,500 nitwits
bankrupting a billion dollar company is
they got a bag of rocks and we're flying
f eighteens, Adam blowing all our cash.
Fuck all of that.
Eli Manning is being sat on Sunday.
I got a buddy money.
He flipped out so bad.
He's actually betting against the
giants. It's like, dude, if Gino sucks,
which I don't think he's going to,
no one knows how good Geno Smith is.
He played on the jets.
No one knows how good anybody is when
they play for the jets. Did the jets.
Sorry everybody out in Queens. But you
know there's an element of truth to that.
Okay? The patriots used to
be like that. All right,
so there is hope for you guys.
God knows bill Bellacheck is 70 years
old and we all saw Tom Brady's try to
recover that bad snap the last week.
Right.
You saw when he was running after
that thing, he looked as age.
He looked like a guy who
forgot to set as parking brake.
It was hobbling after his fucking
car and then realize like,
I'm not going to break my leg.
I don't fuck it.
I got insurance on this car and
it just flopped on the ground. Um,
if Geno Smith shits the bed,
Eli is going to be back
in the second quarter.
And by the way,
this happens to every quarterback,
no matter how good they were, no matter
how good of a class act, they weren't.
This happens to it. But what the
fuck happened to Peyton Manic?
Okay.
After all those years of standing there
with at least 19 inches of his 42 inch
neck exposed between his
helmet and his shoulder pads,
it finally fucking gave out.
And what did that fucking Guy Jim or say,
okay.
Ah,
the fucking national enquirer
of fucking sports owners.
He turned his fucking
back on him. Okay. It.
Peyton Manning, he went to fucking eastern
Europe. He went to Transylvania, right?
And he got fucking child's blood pumped
into his fucking or whatever the hell it
virgin blood pumped into his fucking neck.
And he comes back to Jim or say it says
[inaudible] [inaudible] right. Whatever.
That whenever the fuck he talks,
why don't you put me in
this week? Whatever the fuck
he said to them, you know,
probably made more money doing that
and then it'll put water right.
What did Jim or say say he said Peyton,
with all due respect,
fuck you and your fucking
three feet and neck.
We'll move on on what tank and the rest
of this season so we can get Andrew Luck.
That's what the fuck happened. Look
what happened to Brett five rhe right.
Be fucker. He actually had to
go to the jets. Eli Manning,
all these guy with his
quiver and bottom lip.
All he's gotta do is sit on the fucking
bench for a couple of place. That's it.
It's all you got to do.
Everybody losing their fucking minds.
How could they go this?
How could they do the exact same fucking
thing that they'd done to everybody?
I don't remember the end of Derek Jeter
as career when all those sports writers
were fucking bitching about him
saying he's a, he's costing the team.
He's too fucking old.
Should they move him over to first base?
This happens to everybody.
You know?
You don't think that
talking about me right now?
Yeah,
the way I'm fucking look in these days.
I have like three friends of
mine that are are, I love them.
They're the biggest New York fans ever
and I got like fucking phonebook level
texts about what was going. You think
it's going to end pretty with Tom Brady?
This guy wants to play the least like 60
it's some point or fucking Bob Kraft is
going to have to sit down and be
like, Tom, it's you're too old.
I mean look at yet you still
have a Beatle mania haircut.
What fucking year did
you come in the league?
You got to fucking Moe Howard haircut
with the fucking part. I mean,
I don't even know what to tell fucking
Bill Clinton was still president when you
came in.
MMM.
Yeah.
I Dunno what to tell you. This happens to
every, but yeah, it's obviously a shame.
Eli's fucking great. Uh, I gotta tell you,
it sucks is a patriots fan watching
the giants just fucking dismantle and I
wanted one more crack at them.
We had nothing to lose.
You already kicked our ass fucking twice.
We'll come back like tex
Cobb for a third one.
And I was loving and there would always
be an asterick even if the giants made
the Superbowl. And even if with the
Patriots made the Superbowl this year,
if they came back without Tom
Kauflin and we won that one,
that still would be at, at, that
still wouldn't be the same. They went.
That's the level of respect that I have
for fucking the giants organization.
Tom Kauflin and Eli, Alicia Manning. I'm
just breaking your balls. New York fence.
I know. It sucks. You know what?
It really is all you guys flipping out
and you're acting like you love Eli
Manning,
but you really are,
is you're a bunch of selfish cons
because watching eli gets benched is just
reminding you of how fucking old you're
getting and now we're all going to die.
It reminds you of your own mortality.
So rather than deal with that,
you call it sports shows,
losing your fucking voice,
you know,
and meanwhile we're fucking blown $1
billion a month fighting people who have
sling shots in a bag of
dynamite. Um, anyway,
um, I swear to God, if I was running,
this is how I would handle isis.
I would just fucking
take, I would, I would,
whoever those fucking gamers are that
at got to play on the giant TV screen in
Dallas Cowboys Stadium.
If you're good enough to do those
guys who had those drone races in,
in that stadium,
that would be my defense against Isis,
some intelligence and that I have those
fuckers sitting in cowboys stadium when
the cowboys didn't have a game and I
just have them flying around, you know,
blowing up at jungle Jim's. I mean,
that's how I would handle it. Okay.
And considering I haven't even physical
fiscally researched this on any level.
I haven't talked to anybody who's even
remotely informed about what's going on
over there.
The fact that I did this in my
own self contained think tank,
I cannot even begin to describe to
you how much this makes sense to me.
You know, come on dude, you got,
you don't sit by yourself sometimes
and just start solving all the world's
problems. You start walking
around your house whispering,
pretending you're getting interviewed by
Oprah. Come on. We all do this though. We
Oprah sitting across from you. Do
you consider yourself a hero? Um,
is you sitting there muttering to yourself
and then somehow you come into your
fucking present,
need you to sit in there scrubbing like
a fucking old rice checkoff a bowl.
Okay.
And you have,
let's split second of just really stepping
outside of yourself and being like,
well I'm really,
I'm a fucking crazy person.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden the front door
opens and you family walks in and you'd
go right back into character
and they have no idea.
Yeah.
Could you stand in there with this
phony smile and awareness sweater?
I'm sorry. Anyways, a
happy trails. Matt Lauer,
you know, you did a hell of a job waking
everybody up, uh, for the last 20 years.
And uh, hey, you got a little sideways.
How do you buy a sex toy for somebody
you work with and then write a letter?
I mean, Jesus for, what?
Did she just walk around with a fucking
neon sign around your Goddamn neck?
I swear to God.
These people get to successful and they
just like wanting to sabotage their own
fucking career. Oh. Although
maybe he's just like old school.
He came in, he came in the
league when that we'll all
right. He was, I don't know.
Okay.
When you could do that,
cause you gotta think when
he first started buying
like fucking shit like that.
If it was the late nineties, when you
think about the cell phone technology,
texting didn't even exist. There was
none of that shit. There was no Facebook,
there was nothing.
Um,
tell me what could that one poor woman do?
Reg Run off a bunch of copies,
put them on telephone poles.
It just so you know,
and then he just had my assistant
run out and tear him down.
Matt Lauer screaming from the window.
I said turn right.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno. Anyways, I'm
going to be in New Mexico,
in Albuquerque, New Mexico,
south west part of the state. Um,
he's part of the country and I'm
going to be an Arizona this weekend.
Come on down. I mean, you
have to route 66 casino.
Where the fuck am I going to
be in Arizona? I like Arizona.
Doodah Doodah because it's only an hour.
Oh,
wave on a southwest flight
again on the fucking plane.
I listened to their stupid jokes.
Then they say we're beginning
our initial [inaudible]
please raise all your tray tables
in your seats. Please welcome.
This fucking thing isn't loading.
Why is my signal for work?
Okay?
Oh, Jesus Christ. Well, we'll get
back to this, by the way, by the way.
Thank you for everybody who was buying
tickets to the Patrice O'Neal comedy
special. I'll comedy benefits. Sorry,
I'll be promoting this right
up until February, Tuesday,
February 20th,
2018 7:00 PM at the city
center in a New York City,
the sixth annual Patrice O'Neal
comedy benefit, benefit, benefit,
and we keep adding more people.
All right.
We just added the Great
Jim Norton Jandy Norton
a Brendan Burns, p Corey Ellie,
Joe De Rosa, Sam j Robert Kelly,
Jessica Carson,
SciFest sounds and rich
Ross and myself will be,
they're honoring the memory of the
best standup comedian I ever saw live.
All right,
and where am I going to be in Arizona?
I'm going to be at the
desert diamond casino. Oh,
I'm just a fucking dirt bag this week
and I route 66 casino in the desert
diamond casino in Sao route.
I sat how Rita Saturday that Arizona.
This is the degenerate tour.
Um,
and then on December 10th
I just added this date.
I'm going to be at the Arlington
Theater in Santa Barbara, California.
All right. Santa Barbara.
Speaking of Oprah Winfrey,
one of her giant houses is update.
Maybe she'll show up to the show. Um,
I'm going to be up there and then December
14th will be at the hard rock live in
Hollywood, Florida in December 16th,
Bob Carr Theater in Orlando, Florida.
And on the 15th, I'm going to them magic.
I got to get some tickets for that,
by the way. I got to figure out what
the fuck I'm doing over there. Um,
anyways, so when I read some
advertising here, what else did I want?
All my ribs are feeling better in
case you were asking in case you were
wondering.
I got Mizzou and I'm trying
to lay off the drums.
I'm trying. Um, did, I mentioned that I'm
building a drum room finally in my house.
I've had it. I've had it with having
to drive to go to my fucking drums.
Just having a kid now you got to wait
till they take a nap and then you run out
there and for fucking 20 minutes
to an hour and six minutes,
he play fucking drums with the
little kid monitor there. Right.
So you can see when she gets up,
then they go back.
And that's how I'm going to do
it. That's, that's my game plan.
Um, you know what? He actually did,
I have almost every modern
drummer from the 1980s and um,
I was looking at him the other day and uh,
I saw that old Steve Jordan one that
they didn't like 86 or 85 where a Dave
Garibaldi broke down his ghost notes and
all that shit for messing with the kid.
I got to get that down. I got to learn
that shit. That's my next fucking goal.
All right.
My goal isn't to become a better person.
My goal is to recreate what was already
created and then hope that somebody
notices and is impressed by me.
Um, all right, let's read a,
We got four reeds here today.
Can you guys hang in here and listen
to me read out loud for the next few
minutes? Okay. If you think the bullshit
I was saying was remotely amusing music,
this part will be hilarious.
We're exposed really my level
of intellect. All right.
Tipsy elves,
everybody.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year.
If you want bragging rights for the most.
Talked about sweater at your
Christmas parties. Listen Up.
Talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on the website.
I've yet to go on it.
I don't know anything about these.
I know that hipsters love this
shit. Hey hipsters. Here we go.
Tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweater designs that are like nothing
you've seen before. This is where
they show my, I show my age.
I don't think Christmas sweaters are ugly.
I think they're very festive. Uh, the,
it's like wearing an oriental rug
that has like snowmen on it. Um,
they're not for the faint of heart.
Be The life of the Party with
Hilarious Leigh or reverent designs.
All right,
let me look this shit up.
Let's see what fucking tipsy elves is
bringing to the table here. All right,
this saying they're fucking hilarious.
I sit there saying I'm remotely amusing
and these kinds have the balls to come
on and start talking all this shit.
You know,
like they just put out a Chris rock
level fucking special. Alright,
tipsy elves.com. All right,
let's see what they got here.
Let's see how Jesus, okay. All right.
These guys are definitely bringing it.
What the fuck?
Uh,
oh my God.
Okay.
They got an Obama one that
says miss me yet on the back,
they should have all his drone attack
with a list of all the people who weren't
terrorists. Can we fucking be balanced
in this country? Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't understand this hero
worship of that guy. I really don't.
What did he do? You know what
the best thing about Obama was?
He could deliver a fucking speech,
you know?
And I don't even know how good he was
considering he was in between Bush and
fucking trumps. So that's
really like, you know,
that's really setting the bar for
like low. He, he for me one, she,
you're not going to fool me again.
I mean, how do you not follow that?
And then I don't know what this other guy,
but Donald Trump is so fucking bad. He,
I actually had this thought the other day.
Well thank God Mike Pence is in there.
Um, okay, I've got to give it up
to these guys. A tipsy elves. Yeah.
If you want to fucked up looking sweater,
these guys are definitely uh,
definitely crushing it. I like the suit
though. I gotta be honest with you.
I am actually digging
the soup. Um, anyways,
while you're shopping
for your ugly sweater,
checkout their holiday attire for
yourself or as a gift like adult onesies.
Oh boy. Oh boy isn't it? Isn't this, this
is a weird time to sell adult dunk ones.
Isa Is there a picture of the,
of the latest guy who got fucking ousted
out of his career for buying sex toys.
They even sell wild and crazy ski suits
for your, you skiers out there for men.
Three piece Christmas suits.
I thumbs up to those interactive sweaters
or they consensually interactive a
beer pong corn hole gross and
hilarious holiday teas for women.
The holiday leggings,
he always got a whore it up for you guys.
Sweater dresses and cozy adult onesies
specific sizing for men and women so
everyone could get the perfect fit.
Right now.
My list is a get 20% off tipsy
elves.com when you use my code Burr,
but you are are at checkout, that's 20%
off. Anything you order on the site,
go to [inaudible] dot com enter my
code burr at checkout to get your 20%
sitewide discount.
That's tipsy elves.com
and my code bur bur are,
oh look who's bag. Endo G. Okay.
Talk about how every man looks
better in a suit. You know, guys,
when I sit on the promenade checking
out who's going to be my next boyfriend,
I have to admit I am,
I gravitate to a guy's junk
that's in a three piece suit.
I don't know what it is. I just feel like
he's going to be a little more classy.
Um,
can you can choose from 100 from hundreds
of top quality fabrics and customized
all the details including
your lapel jacket lining,
monogram and more in dope.
CIDO has been featured in major
publications including Gq,
Forbes, and the fat. I
think douchebags read Gq.
Don't take what kind of an asshole has
that kind of fucking time to pick out.
Like the perfect pen and pencil set.
There's what you write out your fucking,
you know, $64 to the electric company,
I'm sorry,
Forbes and fast company and are now
the largest made to measure men's wear
company.
Here's how it works.
Like Gq magazine is for somebody who
fucking wants to act like they're like an
international spy but isn't one,
you know,
it just kind of fucking old people
out of their pension. I'm sorry.
Anyways,
uh,
visit a showroom or
online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customizations
and submit your measurements.
Place your order and wait for it to
arrive. And just a few weeks this week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino
suit for just 359 bucks at Indochina.
yeah.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for made
to measure premium suit plus shipping
is free.
That's indochino.com promo code Burt for
any premium suit for just $359 and free
shipping and credible deal.
For a suit that will fit you better
than anything off the rack ever could.
Ah,
who's back?
Me On ds me on d is why are
we fighting these doses?
But Dude, dude to brds
Biondi you go. I did.
I fucking pick dudes.
I've been Robin lately on this song.
Why do I keep doing? I got to pick up
easier word to rhyme with that. I'm,
I'm been just been off my game lately.
You know,
Mandy's Mandy's Isis is on a jungle
gym do to do to me undies. Mondays.
We can beat him with the Slim Jim.
Why go down that road bill?
Every year millions of people receive the
least like gift of all time, underwear,
underwear, right? Even if you get your
wife some sexy underwear, that's kind,
it's kind of a gross gift, isn't it?
I guess on some level she's psyched.
You're still attractive, but you know
what you really are saying, you know, oh,
come on. You know, what are you
saying? You know what I mean?
I'm surprised feminists haven't
brought that up. Lingerie is slavery.
Um,
but we still give it to our families
and our loved ones who just wanted,
isn't that a weird sentence
to just read out a contest,
but we still give it to our families and
our loved ones who just don't want it.
It's kind of rapey. Uh, but maybe it's
not that underwear is the problem.
It's the kind of underwear.
Let me tell you about me undies be Andy's
the only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift.
Me undies,
me undies may underwear the perfect gift
that everyone's going to love for you.
It's a God damn holiday.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle this year.
Don't give me underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season to
get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee. Go to me undies. Dotcom. Slash.
Bird. That's me undies.com/bar.
Oh my God. Look who's back.
It's Mvmt movement watches
the holiday season.
Dooby dooby do is fucking
here with movement watches.
You can skip the crowds,
you know,
standing behind that
woman with her white ass.
So anything worse than a wide flat
ass with no signage on it, you know,
at least you could do is fucking,
you know, rent it out, right?
We'll be back with ASCE shaming.
You could skip the crowds and standing
in crazy lines and find a gift they'll
love at prices that beat
department stores movement watches.
Start at just 95 bucks.
All right?
Just throw it in a stocking handed
to the person. Get on with your life.
Put some bourbon in your eggnog.
You had done at 95 bucks
at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks.
Sorry. Moving watches at just 95 bucks.
Edit a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks,
okay?
Uh,
for this kind of a watch,
because you can get about what you
get to watch for like 95 bucks.
But it's like a fucking Timex movement
figured out that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the
middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible price.
Had such great prices. Movement,
watches make wonderful holiday gifts to
classic design, quality construction,
and styled minimalism.
Over 1 million watches
sold in over 160 countries.
It gets 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement
watches.com.
That's mvmt.com this watch has a really
clean design that makes it great fashion
statement.
Now it's time to step up your watch game.
Go to MVMT watches slash
burr join the movement.
All right. Okay. I think, is that
it? I think that's like 28 minutes.
Um, yeah, I'm going to
try, you know something.
I'm going to try to get out
and do some standup tonight.
I think I'm going to do that cause I
got some gigs the next couple of nights.
Right? Go out there, shake
the fucking dust off.
I've been in the edit room almost every
night of this week. Okay. Only two nights,
but it felt like every night with my add.
Um,
we are currently editing season
three of f is for family.
Um, I don't know when it's going to be.
It's going to be out later on next year.
Uh, that's how it works. Animation.
It's a very slow process. But, um,
I'm really loving how this
season is coming together
and I'm hoping you guys are
too.
And if you don't,
then I guess we won't get a season
four and if we don't get a season four,
I will be sad. But I also have a lot of
free time, so it's one of those deals.
So who knows,
who knows what happens there.
Maybe I'll just take the show and just
start fucking putting it up on my website.
Maybe I'll do something like that.
That would be stupid building.
You have to finance it
yourself and you'd go bankrupt.
Just fucking watch season three. So I
could stay with my cushy deal at Netflix.
Can you do that for me? If not, can you
go to the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit?
Uh, I'll be announcing more
special guests as we go.
We might have a surprise guest at night.
We're reaching out to some people.
We'll see what happens. Um,
it's always a great night.
We always tell Patrice stories,
we'd give each other shit and uh,
it's obviously for a great
cause. Okay. That's it.
Please enjoy the music as we transition
into a, an old school Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning podcast
from a Thursday from, I don't know,
years gone by or possibly earlier
this year. I have no idea. That's it.
Have a wonderful weekend.
You can't and I will.
I will talk to you on Monday.
Okay.
Same.
We break
other,
there's this youtube video that we go.
Bill Burr was telling us that he found
a fine video club called best, uh,
best wrestling Promo ever starring. This
guy jumped at Jeff Farmer. I'm judging,
I'm guessing that it's from like the 80s,
and this is before Vince
Mcmahon sewed everything up.
So it's an independent wrestling thing.
I don't know. I don't know where at,
but this guy is legit. So basically what
it is, is this guy jumping Jeff Farmer.
He's got, you know, he's going to promote
your show. Then Jeff Farmer jumping,
Jeff Farmer,
he's going to promote his big wrestling
match coming up on the Saturday.
He's going to do the ric flair thing.
I'll read something.
He's supposed to be doing that shit
and eat. It. Might have a little, uh,
a little bit of a tough, tough time.
We've all been spoiled by the, uh,
nurse of the wrestlers and, uh, how,
how they're able to rock the mic and
really get on there and ad Lib and talk.
And, uh, this guy apparently
doesn't have the skills.
He's still in the development phase.
I'm not going to judge his entire career.
Right. He got salmon here.
He's a wrestling expert.
Sam as an expert. I mean, yeah,
it will really come running down
the hall with those floppy feet.
We've got to promote that. Kevin Smith's
calling the show today too. Oh yeah.
Show just keeps getting better and better.
Oh my God.
He tweeted a while ago that he's,
he's sleeping on his phone right now,
so, so they wake them up for the,
uh, the interview today. So, uh,
Kevin Smith in about 15, 20 minutes.
All right, let's check this out.
Best Wrestling Promo. Ever earlier
we talked to jump in Jeff Farmer.
No, now do that interview. Both.
There's jumping Jeff Farmer hello back.
What a Matthew had with mildly. Yup.
Probably the hardest back
I've ever had in my life
when things aren't going my way.
Motley Crue,
you turned the tables on me,
you've turned the tables in a wrong way.
You've got me mad now.
I'm still around.
I've listened to everything you had
to say. I did everything necessary.
But when you turn around and you back
there me one way or another and you freak
me out of what? Quite filling
mine when I get angry. No,
I'm the one doing the challenging.
I'm issuing a challenge to you motley
crew in the ring with me this time.
Um,
going full bore.
Yup.
And Joe Farmer.
That guy is the worst.
10 is the worst intro ever.
Get your ass kicked last week.
Yup. Yup. Yup. Motley crew's
panic on his face. Like he looks like
he's good. That's what I was supposed to,
I was supposed to go on with this shit.
He looks like he's going to piss himself.
What? I guess I'm just saying he
played the fake staying in one point.
Is that True Sam? How's he look
familiar? I don't think so.
He never had a career in wrestling really.
Someone was trying to say he's
in the wrestling hall of fame,
the w whatever the whatever
that is. Awe. Oh no,
he's an IPW. No, I fucking get Sam
started health deal school. Yes ma'am.
I thought you knew everybody. You
don't know now. I'll give it around.
I've listened to everything. Know that
guy. Oh no, go ahead. You got another guy.
What are you doing thing you had
to say and get everything. Oh,
give a list of when you Carlo Round and
you back there me one way or another and
you beat me out of what's rightfully
mine. That when I get angry. No,
I'm the one doing the challenging. I'm
assuming a town to you, Motley Crue.
Get in the ring with me
going full force
job and Joe Farmer, that
guy's plastic too, by the way.
All Wrestling Promo bloopers are,
she's a genius and great.
Kim Proterra it. This is fantastic.
Some bloopers out there, dude.
Have you ever seen the one where booker
t calls Hulk Hogan the n word and then
grabbed his head cause he's
humiliated holding calls. Tony Atlas,
a black boy back when
he was a thunder lips.
This one's great.
Whoa,
whoa.
I should
take the best is when he turns around and
he looks at the girl and his crew like
Vince is going to kill it, so yeah. Yeah.
He
should have been able to
say what you sound good
wrestling promo genius.
It's genius.
LEX Luger's genius.
The Lex Luger blooper right there.
Lex Luger one.
Yeah.
The best part is he goes to cover his
face and then he makes it look like he's
rubbing his hands.
He's thinking maybe this will fly
after all, so I got to cover up.
That just fucked up the whole time he's
got his chest, his pecs doing that,
moving up and down. This one, this
one's good because it's taken,
like when they do smack down,
they tape it to rebroadcast
and they edited sometimes,
but if you have a satellite dish you can
pick up the satellite feed and watch it
live. So they got the satellite feed of
whole Kogan just completely like fucking
starting over.
Okay.
Oh,
he messes up in front of him.
I have something to do with building.
This company just makes you sick.
The fact that I am the one that
put this company on the map,
it helps you make it what it is today
that makes you sick to your stomach
brother.
Yeah.
Are All those weird chats with you
have all those billions of dollars,
the houses that your kids within the
$20 million vacation home and blah,
blah blah, blah, blah. Shut up
just by ass.
Starting to believe in your own bullshit.
Hogan.
I could have had anybody
play the part of Hulk Hogan.
I could have had anybody bring whole in
one second McMahon.
You actually think anybody
cut a with Hulkamania.
Look at all the guys.
You take the ball to look at
all the guys that had the belt.
Look at all the guys.
The the goal.
I know nobody ran as hard and
as long as I did make man,
it sounds like a real argument.
If you actually think I was just
the right guy at the right place.
If the Ra at the right time
really say it one more time
so you completely understand.
If you actually believe mine,
if you actually think that
I was just a right gay guy,
right place, right time.
Well then Europe picker,
delusional pastor that I fucked.
You are McMann.
Yes.
Campania going wild
and do what I say right now.
Mcmann right now. We just settled
a couple of weeks ago.
They just paddling.
And you were the one that I wanted
to get in the ring. You were the one
goes off forever. Sam
there. Sam, what happened?
Oh Man, we've got a good
bit here. Losing him.
You'd go with a fucking minute that they
really did mess up, didn't they? Yeah.
What the fuck is it sounded like
a regular. All right, let's go.
He said this is good.
You better make up with the select slugger
and the Kemper Taro one dude. Yeah,
that does do that. One
next. All right. Lex Luger.
Mr Lugo. Mr Luger, I saw it just
happened out there with Ron Killins.
I just want to ask you,
I mean,
what are your plans for the next
show is super bowl Saturday. I mean,
are you going to take care of Ron Killins?
What kind of disgusting.
This big,
clickable lack of respect does that Billy,
what's his name?
Show book it a match
for the total package.
Lex Luther and super pro Super Saturday.
What is he doing? You know it's called
super boss Saturday. Can you
afford to pay me and Russell? Ron,
I don't know. I'm going
to let him stars. God
marriage took big us right
Achilles. Look at me. I'm a package.
I will
rip them apart. I'll
piss down. Fuck that up.
Oh,
I don't think I stunk royally.
Even the interview where he
has his whole costume on,
but his voice is just
regular regular voice.
Come to the point.
What's that?
What's that one sound?
This was Kim's Tara fucking gene and
a lot of metal title for less than 48
hours.
It can be quite so coffee
come to the point completely.
It's really Hurghada hand.
He tried the thing ahead, man on me.
There's going squad. Dang. Palm Sunday.
Anyways, Hercules
Hernandez. Mr. Wonderful.
Paul Andar you I'd been familiar before.
If I'm filling a million right now in the
third turn my back. I didn't want that.
You what happened with
me like the duty yard dog
and the goon squad.
I didn't pay.
I didn't recover. It only covered
while you recuperate beyond that.
I am full
watch gene open.
She never goes to the bathroom that
are going on in the real genius.
I think he was laughing
when he said 30 yards.
It's just a matter of time. Like
I said before, I thought to,
you mean can I put it to everybody?
It's just a matter of time like yeah,
but tower here that runs
the world wrestling,
her world wrestling federation
has done like, Hey, can't go on.
Right.
You're all going to go down one by one
and I'm going to make sure that for the
weapon that you gave me,
whoever you're like our restaurant is
that type of treatment.
Did it change?
You guys want to do, bring
it up, turn around and I say,
I'm going to carry the start for a while,
but I do and I view all right,
what a beat.
Yeah.
I have a little too visual because
this, someone's been a, this
is, it sounds really good,
but there's a couple of things coming in.
A botch mania on youtube and shock
master master. You've seen it before.
I think shock masters remaining
is very visual, but a, okay,
here's 10 labs in my life.
Shock. Master's up their shop.
Masters in might be in the top five. Wow.
Shock Master. This is my favorite one.
It's psycho said he doesn't
realize he's, he's alive. Okay.
Y'All fans.
But there are a lot of skeptics that
think that perhaps you can't take it.
How do you address those skeptics?
Wallace skeptics and all the
people that have a little bill
five house
tonight.
There you hear it. A man of
few words sat. Go sit back.
You're alive. Pounds. Let me do that
again. Yeah, we covered phone though.
I made a few words on words.
This is a,
the shock master. Look man.
What's the setup on it?
Basically their version of
it. They were supposed to, uh,
they had a mystery partner and he was
supposed to be like the next big good guy
and WCW. And A, you're supposed
to bust through the wall,
but nobody told him there was a support
to buy for under like at the base of the
wall. Yeah. So he tripped right over
the two by four falls flat on his face.
The entire thing is the
funniest thing you've ever seen.
It's staying in the British bulldog.
A horrendous,
they was supposed to be this big
pump up of the shot massacre.
But when he fought, when, when ric flair,
cause he's one of the greatest of all
time of this surrounded by five bumps.
Awful.
And his reaction to what happened,
I watched this 700 times in the, and
I cry every time. The shock master,
he was just an old wrestler from the date
of you eat from, it was tugboat in Dwi.
He said they put a storm trooper helmet,
literally a storm trooper helmet that
they covered in glitter. Oh sparkles.
Makes sure you have the, the
the the sting lead in. I will.
So this was actually so bad that
this guy had a whole gimmick.
He was going to be the next main event
guy. They changed his entire gimmicks.
So that he was just a
Klutz that always lost.
They couldn't do anything with them
after that because of his debut. Yeah,
Jack.
Other than
what happened already,
helmets and how to go get it
and put it back on his face.
Glittered puttered his fucking head. Do
you think other wrestlers laughed at him?
Voice.
His voice was done by a guy off the set
who had a live mic. Oh, they
didn't tape it. He did it live.
So when he trips, you can
hear them go, Oh God, oh no.
That was Rick
flair. He goes, let me tell you something.
You watched the whole thing would at home.
You don't understand.
The home
vicious was doing a bad promo.
Now we just watched too bad for all those
British bulldog and sting were awful
and ric flair had,
this was like the Rick flesh show,
so he was trying to put this together at
flair. Flash trying to buck, but when,
when he fell through the
wall, ric Flair, when,
Oh God,
that fall the greatest thing forever.
How bad the Promo we up to that point,
he's panicked grabbing for that helmet.
And this is in front of an audience,
the live audience,
and it's live on TV.
This is their big thing
leading up to a paper view.
Live television by the paper view so you
could see this guy that was supposed to
be debut.
This is
perfectly clear. They're expecting
big things from the shock man.
Maybe the next hole,
this thing right it completely
to yet for the most,
the whole thing going to stay on.
If you have a wrestler, he wrestled
a little low on this.
This is the best.
Bear with us a little further so he could
get something more lead up. All right,
good
admissions bad.
They're all nervous cause flares.
They're square. It's just like disgusting
yelling.
That's the
worst outfit I've ever seen.
Listen,
it looks like he's wearing
a pumpkin on his tag.
He said,
oh my God.
Held up
shaking his head.
He's got to put his helmet on because
the other guy's going to do his promo for
him so you can't see his mouth shut.
It's in the top labs
just because it's not even a
regular restaurant. The shock
must must've breakthrough.
I watched.
I watched this alive in 1993 it's the
greatest moment in pro wrestling history.
There's never been a better [inaudible].
It's killing me.
Eight different things that you think
they watched this and just laugh.
They did. It completely destroyed
his career. Not only do you have to,
you have to be as quiet as you can because
you can hear Rick flair say, Oh God,
you can hear offset
where he's supposed to,
where he's getting ready
to do his promo for them.
You can hear them making fun of him,
laughing
to yourself if you can this hell.
I've been through the mall. I was
trying to drill a hole, you know,
and we're doing his costume of injustice.
He had a,
for a giant fur vest that was
three quarter lane buttons,
a giant sparkly helmet and jeans and boots
and no shirt shop master.
The shock master wasn't an ass.
They literally, after this show,
they changed his entire gimmick.
He became a construction worker
that constantly falls down.
That was his career
bell's palsy.
The stroke master keeps having them.
Okay guys, shock Mr rules. I don't
think I'm going to be able to license.
This is the greatest thing I've ever
seen telling you to smoke. Okay.
Everybody can change so I will try.
It's like big Jack Jack.
His voice hasn't started yet.
You see him,
you see him motioning with his
hands and voice didn't start yet,
but guys behind stage isn't talking yet
so he's just motioning like he's talking
like he's a mine. None of them
said you fell through the wall.
Jack [inaudible] like Yo,
I'm actually impressed with this guy
to be able to yell without laughing.
He's so bad. He probably
didn't know it. Still
no muscles at all. He's terrible.
He's got the shot to producer.
He's got to get my stomach stapled.
I keep breaking the wall and falling.
I wish we could hear the audio better.
Try to nail a founds the logo to the
these pummel you with how cupcakes are
made.
Dvt and
he fell and this is a thing too,
if you shit fell.
No hands on his head like sweat on his
fucking fucking stupid helmet and his
Elma with fallen.
He's gut down on the fucking floor like a,
what is sand pail on his head?
Oh
No. Stopping him. So when
he puts the helmet back on,
I love the fact that
that he's standing there,
he has to wipe the ground dirt off the
dust
and look at staying as bad. All I have
to say is he's calming everybody down.
I hit the moment. All I have to
say is I'll part is going to shock
my row
once off.
Timing was,
I got to see it again. You get to
talk Yo. Yeah. Do you want to hear it
really hard to hear the whole outfit.
Everything but it does make a mistake.
It doesn't have a body. Terrible. Hello.
Wait, stop it. Stop it. Stop
it. Stop it. Stop it. I'm sorry.
You got to understand too.
This was sid vicious and the Harlem
heat and they were beaten up.
A British bulldog is sting for like months
and this is the guy who Dan is going
to match the intensity.
These are the top three guys,
the top bad guys in the company,
top good guy,
and they had no one with
them the day that this is,
the guy ain't fucking got to stop
Doron
foot or less.
I would love to know what they're like,
what is the shock master thinking after
his helmet goes on and he's like, I just
is this big mom.
Oh,
I wish I could see that from behind them
is the best on someone tweeted that they
made fun of this on raw recently? Yeah.
Oh good. Yeah. We get it with the club
shit where I get you to clap right here.
All right, good. Yeah.
Supposedly they went real inside
and made fun of this one wrong.
It's all a year ago. Less
than a year ago. All right.
Here's one more from the shock master.
Yeah.
Jack Door,
man.
He just fell.
There's no two by four that he just fell,
wait a minute,
this is what he's doing and he's waiting
for that guy to start telling you want
to. He yells, he thinks it's his voice.
Pantomiming the guy was yelling at him.
He thinks that it's his boy,
his backstage voice guy,
but it's not if the guy
can't even pay to mine
is this five seconds,
which seems like a million years where
every one is collecting themselves.
Audience, the front flap, the shot master,
everybody went,
Holy Shit.
His helmet so discombobulated.
What he's hearing is what
he's supposed to be saying.
There is a storm trooper helmet.
He got the Holloway.
Yes. Yes. It's not an exaggeration.
That's the storm troopers.
Storm trooper helmet with Glen
Brown and he went to the next style.
He got the captain caveman and cap his
jeans that he drove to the arena and I
think I heard a better version from
the guy that just tweeted me, hey man,
I gotta wake up at nine 45 I got to go
to the airport. You got to go bill. Yeah.
I came by to say hi and we appreciate it.
Yeah,
he's going back to, I will. I will
be back next week. Yeah, next week.
Any time there will be back on the show
next week. All right. Thank you Mr Bern.
Keep up the podcast.
I'm a big fan belt upon.
Take it Isabelle and it goes
this shot they're all looking at.
Then go into shock.
Master just fell through.
They all see the whole kid going
down the toilet. Could you go back?
Can you go into shock master on raw?
Just see if it's a better clip.
Shop master on Ra is the, is the, is
the shock master on wrong? Like that's,
that's the one they made
fun of him. That's not the
original shock master. Yeah,
they have a a clip of it though in the
beginning just to set it up. All right.
What'd you go with this?
That I just want to stop the [inaudible]
want you to hear his promo now let's go.
No,
they call me the shock master,
but you're just felt the world
good. Come on in. You want why? Why?
Sure.
All ready.
Hello.
Can you pause this glitter?
I think he has a glitter
stormtrooper helmet
on his chest.
From what he found
fucking storm trooper helmet sparkles.
And why is it all scared of him?
Cause he looked all scared.
Why didn't he turn around Douche bag?
He just fell through the fucking wall.
Shock master is a dud and
the promo is terrible.
Be this brutal villain. This
guy from another planet. Oh.
Oh my gosh. Jeans and boots and and boys.
The first thing you see is him
fallen. You want a patient? Me,
I just fell through the wall. Oh
motherfucker. That is so funny.
Now what is the setup on this now is this
is from 19 or 2009 it was a year ago.
They made fun.
I'll see much better audio,
but he doesn't have
his promo on his phone.
None other than
hello.
You heard someone say, what
did he fall to? The 40 fall.
What did he has his backstage or fall?
Oh,
I love this guy.
None other than
I told you.
Oh God
told you. It's just so bad.
It's everything about is
poorly done. Everything,
man.
It's just additive from the original one
to shut out some awkwardness. Oh yeah.
And then one thing I noticed,
yeah, this is when they, uh,
and then rod did a spoof on it a year
ago. Yeah. Cause they were putting out,
when was the original shark master for
1993 I saw the fucking 17 almost 17 years
later. Raw fucking goofed off. Let's
see how they goofed, right? No,
but we just are coming.
I think it's coming from that
wall. You know, it sounds like it's
coming from over here. Yeah. Hm.
Lito
awesome.
Where's the,
where's the voice?
Sounds like it's coming from
right over there. Oh, there it
is.
A crap.
Did they anyone even get it?
I love the shock master
clip. Yeah. Oh yeah.
It's out of a lot of labs I had
and that shop master. That's great.
And then they would dusty Rhodes,
who is one who's probably in the top five,
like my guys of all time to
like dusty and we're flair.
Was The rock the Best
Micah? No, not at all.
Not Probably 91 he might not
have even been a top five.
Really, man, he was great.
Fantastic, dusty. Ric flair.
Flair is better than Roddy
Piper. Um, hi, my name five.
Uh, I'm trying to think us that was the
rock was good at making catchphrases.
How about sergeants? No, no. Um, oh Jake.
The snake isn't in, in the top, in the
top five probably. And um, you know,
not the rock is not in the top five.
Even the top 10 stone call,
it was probably better on the Mike in
the Rocco's it fiber. That's the five,
right?
The Rock was just good at
making catchphrases and
then he is the best though.
Dusty and flare are neck and neck also.
See One,
they're all saying oh and hard. Had a
really good one. Really good blooper. Uh,
yeah, the best blooper of all
time. But come on. Oh, hold on.
That damn it.
God Damn shot master.
That is one of the bat is hysterical.
I like on,
are we able to laugh until I come?
Actually fucking tears are coming down
my eyes and try the own heart. One funny,
I just recently stopped
watching it and laughing.
But you still watch it
with this thing like, wow.
He went right on his fucking head. He's
the worst thing that could've happened.
The worst thing,
dude right there,
and the helmet falling off
and he scrambles to put it
on and it's so clumsy and
they were just standing
there trying to be tough.
Be tough with all the
glitter on his chest.
Hi
Lisa. She's very pissed off.
Yeah, she, yeah. Lisa and Jersey.
Lisa.
Hi Lisa.
The product of woman,
he's wet.
I just can't believe that
women fall for his crew.
Oh, you're an easy mark.
Listen to you. Yeah,
I would get you with and within
within two days of knowing me you'll,
you'll be subscribing. Yeah, right? Yeah.
Just by mean just by your answer, Sweetie.
I can tell you go. This is
classic. Yeah, right. Whatever.
Here's what is on your mind.
I'm an big arrogant, big
mouth fucking asshole. Right?
And you want to curb,
you want to destroy that any way you can.
So here's what you do. If you're pretty,
this is when pretty girls fuck up. They,
they try to hear, hear, giggling.
This is, this is, this is,
here's what pretty girls fuck up.
They tried to get me good.
I'm a fat mother fucker. So what they
tried to do is they play the love game.
They give me something they think
is precious, which is pussy.
That's what girls have to give.
But after
that's an attack mode,
what have a plan can you have on that?
Your pleasant on a tag.
If you want to destroy a man's fucking
arrogance, what do you do to do that?
Other than use your pussy.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Do you hear what she's doing?
The singing because she didn't
really don't have an answer,
but my God,
it's like what else can you do?
Talk about fucking a fringe where we ever
talk about that. Yes, I
could. I innately it mainly,
here's what you got to understand,
ma'am.
We don't like you no matter what.
You know,
we don't care if you know
all the quarterbacks in NFL,
we don't know if we don't care
if you know every team color,
we don't care if you know all the GMS.
We don't care if you
know every basketball,
we don't care because
innately we don't like you.
So you try to infiltrate
your personalities on us
and you realize that you're
not interested in. Then you try
to fuck us when that doesn't work.
Your hours
that you're interested at first and then
look at if I work hard to get what I
want, which is pussy. Right. You agree
with that? That we work hard to get pussy,
right? Yes. What then after I
do what I do. What's your job?
Oh, you did. Don't you
like the companionship or
yes, but in a, in a possession
kind of way. Like, like you,
you go wash this girl cheat. You know
what women have to do grow on you.
My girl been around for four
years. Grow on you. Oh my God. Yes.
You love it.
I can't imagine that you're
dating an intelligence.
Beautiful. She's a genius. Really. She's
fucking a genius girl. I big doctors,
lawyers, teachers, people tell you I
don't make no fucking homeless people.
Retards. No one that dates on
Paxil or no shit like that.
He's telling you, she's telling you
that you just had a miscarriage.
So that sounds like an intelligent woman.
Oh, when I was a goofy bitch.
But that's, that's a bitch.
You fuck when you just meet
the visuals led tape mess
that a miscarriage. That's, that's it.
That's the price you pay when you
meet a bitch on off the street.
That was a snack for portraying. I'm
just talking about like, like the girl,
we would go out to dinner, he would curse
me out for a little while. You would,
you would understand because you innately,
you don't have your own philosophy cause
you're not really saying anything now.
Yeah. Get waiting. When Patrice brought
up the fact that uh, the pussies,
the weapon when they go with, when you
girls go into battle for the first time,
this is before any get to know you get
to know you, whatever it was. It's just,
we know that's all you
want in the beginning.
Well that's all we want. But
in the beginning, I, that's
not all I want to listen.
That's all you got. All you got
is pussy. Why would I try to
sound like that?
You sound like you know,
this is the way I keep
her on track and this is
yes,
I look at your mouth like the,
you can tell there's no guidance in
your life because you're too comfortable
yapping about nothing.
Nothing. Right? Because I'm
a guy and that's what we do.
But you but you, the stuff you
talk about that you think is about,
so you talk constantly.
Thank you.
But it's always interesting when
guys talk. Hi Lisa. Thank you.
We got a couple more here. Let's go
Kevin in Nebraska. Kevin. Hi Guys.
Jump in and find your spot and go.
Hi Dr. O'Neil. Man, you need to shut off.
My wife was showing
you're giving away all my,
I'm sorry man. I only get no good
soldiers in trouble, but this is is,
let's go right to Colorado.
Kirsten, what's up?
Hey, I totally agree with Patrice.
Absolutely agree with Patrice.
Women needs know their place.
No,
what they do do it well and please
their man and their man will be around
forever. Good girl. Wow. Or ever.
Absolutely. Men need a writer.
Be a writer. It's not that
difficult. Keep your mouth shut.
Do what you're told.
Be who you are.
Is that what you're saying? Is that
what you do with your girl? Oh,
hi. Thank you. Karsten let's go
to John and Utah. John deep voice
treat saved my marriage.
I was the, uh, the doting,
the doting husband and
it was all about her, uh,
started listening to him and things were
going bad. And so I started going, Whoa,
whoa. Treats do. I started
following his advice.
What would though
perse, but it's turned it around and
work the happier than we could possibly.
D D shirts you're going to be. She is
what he said his, yeah. What? He said,
we're happy.
A happy man is a happy relationship.
A happy woman is a miserable
man portrayal. Wow.
You want it?
She wanted me to be the man.
That's what they fucking point is.
You got to do a one shot deal,
a relationship advice show
for like one hour, two hours,
whatever you want to handle this.
He is just simple. We'll, we'll,
we'll work that out of Washington.
We'll get Patrice on Neil on the
show by himself. Just taking calls.
Why your relationships? Here's
why you can, here's why.
You should always understand
why it's legitimate.
I'm a fucking mess physically.
Like I'm trauma tried to get a shave one
of these days but naked if you will get
me making it next to my girl,
you will go, what the fuck?
Like my self esteem has to like when I
fuck I have to go, why is she fucking me?
I wouldn't never give me no pussy and
it's like I'm looking at it going,
what is she up to?
This is like my low self esteem.
She got to be an ulterior motive.
My son was, Dave's a low is high.
I go, what is this? But after, but I
stopped realizing it's a mind thing.
All they want, all they want is just a
motherfucking, they can look at and blink,
slow and respect and and you know
it's not about beating them and, and,
and subjugating them.
It's about,
they look at you and feel like they
don't need to be your Mama. That's it.
But they go, wow, this motherfucker is
in my corner. He handles his business.
He now said, this is what I'm
saying. Your House situation,
you become a million times sexier because
that's a man shoe that you did is buy
a fucking mansion. That's a man.
Shit. You bought a mansion Anthony,
so it's like your girl can't help him go
this mother fucker. When you're renting,
she can kind of that other half of
her voice that tries to put you down.
She could look at you and go, this
faggot Wynton at 59 but man, it's not
snake written a house. Pussy ass
Nigga. You bought a mansion again.
Clothes.
She wants you more 59 fine.
You're hotter than he was when he was
renting. It's a fat fuck man. Wow.
That's really good. Hey. Ah, wait. Hold
on a minute. Let's go to John. Jay,
you guys, you got people man reacting.
Oh yeah, John and Pennsylvania.
Hi Patrice.
I'm impressed.
You know how to keep your
woman alive without a contract.
Yeah, man, it's mine. Shit, dude is
mine. I'm telling you, it's like,
it's like is pimping without
beaten. I'm Megan. To Sell Pussy.
It's just stay one back dude. Don't
ever let them convince it on one day.
What will they do without like a man's
guide is you ever see a woman at once?
Like they'd try to,
you see out have success to a woman is
doing as being like a guy. It's like, I,
I do this, I do that. I
do listen VAT and, and,
and we can care less like a sexy man.
Like fuck it.
I'm a female ob like a woman.
A woman has an insane on position.
Always. [inaudible] is not any sexier
than the bitch that works at Mcdonald's.
If she's cute. That's the thing about
us. We've done point. Very good point.
I'll see a woman while she do a
call on you. The black doctor,
Phil black dots wood.
That's the name of your shop.
We're going to give like one or two
hours. See how it goes. Landfill.
It's going to be, there's black
doctor Phil with Patrice O'neil.
Dad's all alright. Uh, Dodds listening.
We got to set that up. You want to do a,
I don't know when, when, when.
It makes sense. It sounds like.
Get my fucking hole man straight like I
just go off with a on an improper turn
on the freaking channel and just let
the phone's ringing and see what happens
for an hour. Yeah, we'll, we'll set
that up in the very near future.
Let's go to turtle from WAC.
Bag it.
Hey guys, listen. Patrice,
you're absolutely right.
I've been jumping through hoops ever since
I met my wife trying to get the pussy
and once he got it,
they put up more hoops to jump through.
I got to go home and implement
the o' Neal standard in my own,
the O'Neill standard.
Wow.
She knows eventually you're going to
figure out if she doesn't constantly apply
pressure that you're going to figure
out. Holy Shit. What? Like my man,
he was nervous that his wife
was going to leave him and I go,
let me ask you a question like if
you really, if we really sit down,
if my woman left,
Yo woman left your woman and you go,
what would you really miss them
exactly like what would you miss?
It's your own arrogance.
Our arrogance is men because
their possessions and if
they leave, it's like, um,
it's like losing your favorite pencil,
but it's like
waiting, waiting, a relationship,
a loving relationship.
Here's a,
maybe your favorite pennysaver putting
what doesn't even sound like it's a
number two pencil.
No,
we break.
Wow.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].